gang that stay trashy tour is coming
into the home stretch baby grab some
ticket and come out and see the boys
little standup comedy plus we play a
little ay with the crowd it's a good
good time yeah uh in November we're
coming to Pontiac Michigan then four
shows in Chicago Illinois limited
tickets remaining for them get those
baby then we're hitting Minneapolis
Madison Milwaukee Sacramento San
Francisco San Jose Washington DC then
we're eding it in Philadelphia two huge
shows at the Filmore get those tickets
that's going to sell out we love you
gang yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is Ru garbage
oh yeah it's that a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find it at the grow to be classy they
just a big old piece of trash garbage
I'm your host a Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in the new edition she's upstairs
doing a little yoga okay listening to
Slayer all right just having a good old
time up there fair enough my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and my best
pal in the whole wide world give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rev subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are TR cooking baby
then obviously the greatest website of
all time I said I once said a two
million times
www.patreon.com garbage gang check it
out it's a fiesta over there it's a good
time man the bald guy ain't lying and
now about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
MCM everybody what up boys shaky leg
over there yeah I'm Juiced up we got the
king of La in here man Los Angeles baby
I brought the OIC let's go the kids love
this guy yeah yeah yeah yeah hell yeah
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest back with us again today
first time in the New Edition we're very
excited he's the host of the stiff socks
podcast he's on tour right now going to
be in Australia down under doing some
comedy shows down there and he's got a
brand new special coming out on Amazon
November 14th entitled pterodactyl give
it up for Trevor Wallace everybody thank
you for having me there he is look at
I'm what's up baby dude I'm back this is
the nicest Studio I've ever seen this is
the opposite of garbage yeah all five of
us live in here so yes okay good there's
a strange man in the lobby who made eye
contact with me that went back to his
Rubik's Cube oh yeah dude he's guyes not
like but like I was thinking about him I
was like does he like tell his family
like oh I'm going to work and then he
just sits there all day yeah well
sometimes it's not even him sometimes
there's an actual mailman who takes his
job and just the Mailman just is the
also the doorman who who eats soup every
day and it smells like shoes soup it
smells like low tie it smells so bad in
the lobby dude eating soup in New York
City is the saddest thing I've ever
heard of my it could be August and he's
just in there crushing a bis it's wild
damn bis is actually I'll give it to it
biscuit bis should be in its own
category yes love Abyss you like better
soup I love Abyss it puts I mean it's
like the crumb brulee of cream you know
it's like it's putting the the soups to
shame yeah it's all right you know I
love you you have an opinion on
everything thank you you have to FIS
right away he's like it's the Crum cream
you know I don't want to come in here
and just be a yes man you know Lobster
bis we're talking right not a pushover
baby I got a pinion no you got to have a
pinion can't oh yeah oh I never really
thought about that oh yeah door
reception oh soup no we're talking
Lobster bis right that would be lober
bis of course yeah love a good she crab
soup's pretty good youever have she crab
down in Charleston never heard of it's
like a lobster bis crab they crab okay
okay there we go 2023 baby buddy what
are you doing let me ask you this please
uh what's your skin routine you putting
anything on there oh man you got a good
Sheen thank you good looking kid it does
really good skin see I'm on the like the
fence of like oily and good skin that's
that's where you want to be like once
the cameras and all the lights are on it
starts to get like a nice glaze to like
a rotisserie on it that's like alente
pasta perfect yeah I uh I'm just a dumb
guy and I uh I was dating a girl and she
had like this long ass skincare routine
it take her like 25 minutes to wind down
and go to sleep and then I started
feeling bad about myself I'm like I just
little bit of water a little bit of Dial
soap night and then she's like oh try
this try that and then we don't talk
anymore and I was like this is the
closest thing I have to her is her show
still the connection yeah so I just went
to a mall one day and there's like a
place called Keels just skin swort and I
was like I just like we know KS what are
we dirt bags over here come on let's the
shoe store right this guy's so
Hollywood I don't know if you guys have
heard of this luxury called a credit
card but I went in there and just the
easiest client in the world just easiest
customer I go I what do I do give me
everything and then this lady just was
like this this this this this and I was
like cool do it all and she goes cool
$400 like it's so expensive God but easy
check for her she probably Clos the shop
down after I left [__] this dumbass
hit the Annie ANS and call it a day it's
like a YouTuber in Miami just being like
give me the Bugatti and they're like sir
where's your papers give it to me all
right here you go yeah it's yours uh I
love I do the same thing I do the under
eye cream I do a little uh uh a little
serum a little this a little that feels
good man yeah it's hilarious sometimes
when I use it too much I get more acne
and I'm like what the [__] Isen happens
to me too it's a fine line you got
relapse and on hygiene I know I caught
myself the other day I realized I'm so
stressed my wife was doing the same
thing I'm like you know what I'll join
in on the skare routine he got to man I
know but she like put some cream in my I
don't know well you know some whatever
and I dude I'm like scrubbing my face
and she's like I think I think you're a
little too tense I'm like what do you
mean I'm like oh man I need to [__]
take s I'm the same way with all my
hygiene my toothbrush is like flat it's
flat dude it looks like it's doing the
YMCA in that [__] it's just out there
that's crazy but like do I multitask
when I brush my teeth so I'll like pause
and then I'll kind of like rest it in my
teeth while I'm like texting yeah and
it's just getting B but like it looks
insane looks like you looks like you
were doing your tires yeah exactly women
are like what what are you fishing for
copper what are you doing I know but
it's normal to me I don't know no
kidding I figured you'd be an electric
toothbrush man no no no I classy guy
like you dude I don't like I you would
think so much of people think my life is
put together it's not like I just dude
I'll use the dentist toothbrush you know
the one they give that was my question
you use that yeah but it's not a good
toothbrush a pyramid skin get you back
oh I didn't think of that yeah [__]
it's free though right but I love that
bag you get it's amazing I feel like I
didn't just get scammed you know you
keep do hold on that bag for a while too
yeah but something about it you're like
oh this is a toothbrush from the dentist
why would they rip me off it's a shitty
toothbrush so you keep [__] up your
teeth to come back yeah do you have how
many toothbrushes do you have just one
do you have a travel one I got a travel
one but it's just one that's in like the
bottom of like a like a shower bed
toiletry and you're like this has been
to De Mo back this thing's got more
miles on spe Airlines in anybody yeah I
don't put my my travel toothbrush
doesn't go in a holster it's just in the
bottom of my bag it doesn't see the
light of D you got a little bacteria in
you you know what I mean help the immune
system this dirt bag stops bringing a
toothbrush and just whatever hotel we go
to he goes downstairs and say I need a
toothbrush and toothpaste that seems
like so much more work I know like he's
in the Army no it's awesome it's freeing
man yeah but like sometimes they give
you like powdered toothpaste or it's
like in like a condiment bag toothpast
where are you staying it's not good Red
Roof van I thought you were doing all
right no no no but but hotels you're
still Rich right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah use my promo code uh but
yeah some well it's not like powder but
it's like in like a condiment like white
bag it might as well be like when you
brush it it like it gets dry that's part
of the juice man I I could see if you're
like I'm not bringing shoes I'll just
buy new cuz that's like a hindrance in
but Ao No but I'm just saying a
toothbrush you have to actively go like
I'm not bringing this you know what I
mean like it's not like a big free thing
it goes in a bag that goes in a bag yeah
there's no you're not saving anything
but so you have double of everything you
have a you're you're ready to rock and
roll do you ever how long do you leave
like say you go on you're on tour you're
out for a couple of weeks you come back
how long is that uh carryon sitting
there the roller back until again it's
just they are laying their butterflied
out there's something nice about that
it's just it's like you're accepting the
defeat you're like ah well I'm going to
be gone at 4 days want yeah my cat lays
on and I'm like this is fine we just got
back uh and at the Airbnb we had a
washer washer and dryer so I just did
all my clothes oh nice did washed all my
clothes now that bag is just open in the
in in the office like a dresser dude I'm
literally just [__] living out of
that thing yeah I don't know if I've
ever washed clothes on the road oh yeah
we a lot really dude this [__] animal
we'll we'll show up in a we'll leave to
go to Oklahoma on a Tuesday we get to
Oklahoma he's like I got to throw a
laundry in I'm like what going airbn we
were at your house 5 hours ago if an
Airbnb has one that yeah and they want
you to use it because they give you the
they give you a couple of couple of PODS
yeah no you guys are doing it right I'm
always playing the game where I'm like
did I wear these boxers yet I did that
today and I think I'm on the losing end
of
that yeah yeah yeah it's like a in my
head I go like oh I'll remember there's
no way you never remember I'm also a big
proponent I've said this before this is
dirt bag science if you leave a pair of
underwear long enough they somehow
refresh they like a couple of weeks if
they're sitting there exactly they're
fresh again exactly they don't it's you
know they're not day old cycle of life
every 48 hours they just return to
normal there was a study just done on
that I heard Andrew huberman talking
about that they come back to life well
it's that thing of like you know they
say like all of your cells in your body
replenish after seven years and you're
like a different person like I think
there's a number at T-Bone look that up
there's a number of like every cell in
your body dies and reach so it's like
you're not the you're not physically the
same person the same thing with
underwear that's like the same logic
when people are like if you swallow your
gum you'll [__] it out seven years later
hear that oh I used to eat I used to we
used to eat Trident with the paper on it
that's crazy cuz they were like yeah you
can just the paper will dissolve I was
like I want to talk [__] but I would do
that with like Starburst in class
Starburst cuz I don't want to make the
noise crinkling so I would just like eat
it with the paper on it's insane wait
you would swallow the pap no raw dog
whole thing what cuz it was in class I
don't want to like make noise and like
there's already
just eating trash well like 100% imagine
looking over and seeing a kid I want to
a scene you see a kid just throwing back
yellow rra Starburst like I'm going to
hide cuz this guy has a gun on him for
sure we're not calling on
Wallace just give you a c and keep it
moving damn favorite flavor of Starburst
pink pink or red got good man yellow's
insane you don't like yellow it doesn't
do anything for me that's like I'm bored
in the bottom of the stop eating the
rapper I don't even know they have
flavor yeah it tastes like trees
yeah I would say uh yeah yellow or or
not yellow sorry pink or red it's got to
be they're the most bold I'll give you
that and you know that because they do a
pack where it's just red do yeah they do
it's just pink and red smart T-Bones got
something what do you got yes so every
seven years for sure but it's this is so
gross to me for some reason you lose 500
million skin cells every day yeah really
they're coming and going dude revolving
door I feel I feel healthy after feel
rejuvenated oh I I sheded millions of
cells this morning [__] am I going to go
to Equinox for I'm already shedding over
here should be a couple of pounds at
least yeah it's got to be nice do you
exfoliate what do you use in the shower
bare hand washcloth bare hand yeah bare
hand gel or bar of soap uh gel okay
whatand gel but I'm not opposed to a bar
I'm a bar you mean body wash not gel
yeah shower gel yeah I'm not in there
with ax hair gel [__] rub I know I
look like I might be um yeah what brand
it's skills the same thing I literally
went in those I was like give me
everything damn do do the whole thing
and is that recurring is that you got
that I just went once and this was like
6 months ago I don't use a lot oh [__]
it's like a quick little dab is little
little dab heels in the shower heels in
the shower what's great is also lady we
see she like oh my God he knows or
they're like who you [__] you have a
girlfriend true yeah where's your
where's your wife yeah if you got two
nice products in here she's like oh no
I'm a home record I'm like no I I just
uh you know I'm a [__] care about my
skin think your roommates were Ray
Jing fresh shower
we got to ask him what get in the shower
okay yeah let's say what kind of shower
do you have is it a glass door or is it
a regular tub it's some [__] it's a
glass door but it's on some Modern [__]
it doesn't have a back half we're going
drop top in the shower that's why nice
hotels have that too and it's like wait
what do you mean doesn't have a back
half like it you just walk right just
half glass oh really it's like you're
[__] showering in a Ural there's just
like a stall door that's a car wash dude
those DS get everywhere it's it and
listen I didn't I went to a new place I
I moved moved and it was already in
there so I didn't like I wouldn't pick
that I like the warmth I've never been
Shou but yeah it's too hot it doesn't
yeah it doesn't it doesn't retain the
heat which is kind of good cuz you get
out quicker but it's like I like when it
steams up a little bit do some thinking
exactly it's not a good thinking shower
I'll tell much okay let's just say
you're at a hotel you're at the Red Roof
in stand you just brush your teeth with
B on Lobster
B um it's a standard shower right it's
like toilet shower MH uh tub like you
know like a tub shower
yeah with the curtain those are great
you turn the water on right let it steam
up a little bit yeah what side of the
shower do you get in you get in the back
far left the back you get in the back
from the back work your way towards it
okay what what are you guys do this
lunatic is just [__] jumping in the
front the front's crazy dude it's nuts
get it over with dude you're like the
front of the line in the Army you're
like just give me everything all at once
got the flag [__] leading the charge
I've never heard anyone do that in my
it's psychopath Behavior yeah that's so
well I guess you get the worst part out
of the way first and then you can work
your way to the back or it just seem I
don't like I don't like that feeling of
tiptoe into it really I like [__]
getting in there and getting under it I
have the water where I want it the
water's hot at the perfect temperature
and I get right in but that's like going
out to a jumping in and then like going
to the beach yes I do that too I got to
get ahead of it pregame in this
[__] exactly you I I respect it
the shower's like all right this guy's
nuts what about your deodorant when do
you put the deodorant on it after the
shirt or before the shirt uh after the
shirt cuz cuz you learn the hard way you
wear a black T-shirt you put it on
before you got all the stains and [__] I
was using Old Spice for years and it was
tearing up my armpit that alcohol you'll
get dude you'll get you'll get a batch
heavy in the alcohol dude I would go
burning I would go in like chlorine or
uh the the C and be my pits be burning
wait we talking about the gel uh yeah
the blue one yeah like the regular old
stick sometimes you I think the gel used
to burn me the one you twist and it
squirts out you can like Google it they
like put like fent on those things like
it's not good keep it coming back
there's lawsuits I know right there's
lawsuits over like it's going to be in
like 2043 like did you a l one use Old
Spice growing up and using the blue like
it like legit Burns so now I got to use
some natural [__] yeah are you what on
Tom's I don't even know yikes KS K's M
company man I don't know yeah brand
loyalty all right not bad um all right
oh sorry I was going to say try to go
three for three cuz I've I've lost on
the on on both of these um but no
interference I said I wasn't going to
talk about it anymore but I'm going to
ask him straight out no interference I
don't know let's say you went out on a
date with somebody yes okay you went to
a restaurant they do specialize in Coal
Oven pizzas okay I like the way you're
finally explaining this you go out on a
date you have an appetizer you order the
salmon as an entree she gets a pizza MH
how do you feel about that I feel great
because I know she's not going to finish
the pizza now I get leftovers God damn
it yeah you is that is that good or bad
I I say it's crazy to order a pizza as
an entree if you're not sharing it it is
a little crazy thank you there you go we
were sharing she
had Toby CLI that Trevor thank you so
much for coming in check out the Amazon
special November 14th best guest of all
time no 14th nov so you got a pizza or
we went out to like a it was like that
the coal oven was like P they're like
it's weird to order pizza at dinner and
it not like I don't think so they didn't
bring over like a [__] 24 in stuff
cross it is a big Flex when they bring
out the tray that they got to put on the
table [__] hul hoop on stilts and
they're like this is for your pizza good
sir salt and peppers underneath it like
a [__] exactly yeah exactly it's got
a little lo I kind like that that means
my a my my meal comes a little you know
couple of accessories well dude it's got
a loft it's cucking the other food it's
like yeah I'm up here baby got the
penthouse floor I also don't like
sometimes like I've seen them they take
it off you ever like they'll have the
basket of whatever they take it off
another table and give it to you like
dude at least walk it in the back and
come don't want your silverware over
here yeah I was at a bar one I never
mind I was at a bar one time I'm like
yeah can I get like you know I don't
know VOD katonic or a rum and coke or
whatever and guy's like yeah no problem
can you hand me that glass over there
and I was like what I'm like just a
random yeah like and I was like I know
you wash them but like I'm not just
there was like a napkin in it I'm like I
got a question for you guys if you guys
get a glass and it's got like a little
bit of a lipstick smear on itend it back
you sending it back we send it back um
lipstick maybe like like light yeah but
if I get kissed and pass if I can see
the lines of the lips I can see your CH
I'm kissing that cup that's the most ACD
I got all week if we get there I'm
[__] that thing dog rubbing it on
your
dick this counts as a score um if we get
there and the glasses are on the table
like say the two wine glasses two water
glasses are on the table I'll take a
peek at it if I have a cloth napkin oh
I'll give that's some soprano [__] I'll
[__] Mar here I'll give him each a
little a little buff Watermark lipstick
is like you got I don't think a waiter
would be like these people that t three
don't like lipstick on their glass water
spots or whatever something we were just
in LA and we went out to like a nice you
it was a nice dinner and uh where you
guys go uh Frankie and jimmies no John
and John and Vinnie John and Vinnie yeah
you were close sounds like an like a
chain you'd see here we went to there
Tony and Tony we went to Melvin's too
which was nice Marvin Marvin [__] this
guy stink godam you give me like the
Kroger brand names all these places the
generic ass version we were at Dukes
yeah then we went to bag cereal for
breakfast good places and uh dude there
was something the guy poured my water
and I guess it was in the bottom of the
cup it was there was like a full Crouton
floating in there and I was like got
like buddy I'm not a guy that calls a
stin but I ain't eating someone else's
crout if you have a little fruit fly
will you just pick it out with your
straw or will you send it back what do
you do with a hair a hair I will eat
around it if the hair is in the water I
just won't drink that hair in the water
That's crazy dude that's never happen
hair in the water yeah You' seen that
like an eyelash or something an eyelash
where are you eating in the valley baby
welcome to the hood no I think um if
there's like let's say get welcome the
mutants everybody if there's a hair in
the corner I just eat around it I just
try not to because it's for me I never
want to be an inconvenience to the group
and if me ordering another omelet yeah
that puts everybody back 30 minutes and
everybody just sitting there while
you're eating that's a that's a that's a
solid move I'll give you that sometimes
it does it I got to be in a mood
sometimes it won't disgust me and I'll
just I don't give a [__] I figured you
would freak out throw the plate who hey
look if the cameras are recording this
is for Tik Tok I'll [__] hit a hit a
waiter right there no I I'm not I just
hate I'm not a confrontational guy like
if I get an Uber and his windows are
down I'm like well that's how the the
ride's going what you're doing yeah yeah
we're getting blow dryer today so I
don't like if that's my meal that's my
meal I say no cilantro it's got cilantro
we're eating cilantro sure you know I
respect that I've gotten a little bit
more used to hair as well I really have
dude that is a crazy statement I kind of
roll with it I'll just I'll just he
brings his
own I'll match you my own we got to stop
by the barber I got to pick up a bag how
are the eyebrows tonight try those yeah
I'll let that slide and the fruit fly
just pop it out yeah don't even sweat it
Kevin talk about Adam and Eve woo baby
I'm hard as a rock talk about getting
fre in the bedroom gang if you're
looking to spice up your sex life MH
Adam and Eve's your One-Stop shop I'll
tell you that they got things you can
jam in you jam out you stick over there
stick in here put your wiener in
something gang flashlights dildos tally
whackers whoer do whoar don'ts whatever
you're into uh they can make those
fantasies come true they're a brand
that's been trusted around for over 50
years years they were they were they
were thror the beaches for positive sex
stuff look at that 50 years ago nothing
but butt plugs in their hands shaking a
bunch of vibrators [__] uh they even
have discreet packaging so if you're
ordering something you don't want the
whole neighborhood to know hey they
don't need to know what they don't need
to know that's the way I see it keep it
button up lock it in you know what I
mean I order the curtain cracked a
little bit if you want to do a little
advertising I I ordered something that
came in discreet packaging shove the
packageing on my ass uh just go to Adam
andeve.com select any one item and use
the code garbage at checkout this is an
exclusive offer just for our listeners
be sure to use code garbage to get your
discount 100% free shipping and Rush
processing so that hard on had hard on
don't go away that's Adam and eve.com
promo code garbage Adam and eve.com Adam
and eve.com code garbage do it uh we got
another big one uh Domino's or Pizza Hut
now Domino's yeah Domino dying in I
might go Papa John's I love his
personality guy insane that guy is nuts
put him on
Rumble uh I go dominoes they've just
I've had brand Lo with them they did the
Butter Crust I don't know what they do
with their cheese but they got those
individual Little Burn spots looks like
it's got polio it's [__] delicious
really good delicious the little yeah
the little brown spots God and you know
what I love about Domino's is that
little pizza track app the app I said
they're revolutionizing [__] me up
that's all fake you know it's like
Antonio's making your pizza they're just
generating [__] they're just saying [__]
but we're but we're right sorry you just
[__] me up that's when you found
[__] back in the day they're usually
there when they say they're there they
timing wise yeah but when it's like
Angelica put your pizza in yeah that's
Reuben's making your they're just
spitballing AI there there's no Reuben
yeah exactly the only thing that bums me
out about Domino's in uh uh in Queens is
they don't [__] come upstairs you got
to go down and get it they hit you with
some [__] I can't I'm not allowed to
go upstairs the [__] out of here I might
as well walk to the store and made up my
[__] only Queens I think it's
everywhere in the city you see did you
see the CP of a YouTuber getting shot
recently yeah did you see his interview
after I did he was he like went up to
the GU like yo what's up baby I'll be
back I mean just the worst yeah that guy
ain't great also it was in a food court
which I think nobody's talking about
yeah he was getting food delivered to a
food court yeah [__] up for one also
who is working for door Dash glocked up
I would be dude came in handy had the ni
I know yeah I don't hate it crazy you're
like getting ready for work you're like
all right phone wallet keys nine he
popped out real quick too he was like
get away from me boom boom boom [__]
kep moving didn't even make eye contact
yeah gave him the legal warning he shot
a [__] wetel pretzels without even
looking sorry you almost hit the
Keels uh uh okay are have you ever
washed your shoes in a washing machine
or a
dishwasher dishwasher people do it yeah
or a hat yeah the Hat I've washed a hat
in a in in a what are they called
dishwasher there we go yeah I'm looking
at my resident expert over here uh
looking at my appliance guy I froze up
real quick air conditioner uh never uh I
think I've done shoes back in the day
but they never come out they they have
like a little Wrinkle in them they need
some Botox in the washing machine not in
the dishwasher dis crazy crazy people do
it it's nuts yeah I've never watched
anything besides plates and a dishwasher
did you ever go through a phase where
you wore a baseball hat slightly to the
left or the right no I'm not a big hat
guy it just really it makes my nose look
too big and then everything on my face
is just projecting brim nose okay I got
that I respect it I want it to be um new
place got a new place rent by bot oo
there it is there it is godamn
homeowner house house no [__] yeah I
love it it's awesome but then again like
I spend money on stuff like that but
then like the the toothbrush you know
looks like he's been looks like he's
been doing up downs for 45 SE seasons
over here David goin's got a hold of
yeah so it's like I spend money on
things like that but like my day-to-day
I don't care um you didn't do any work
in the house right bought it as is I
just as is new furniture no from the old
place pool uh it's got a tub in the back
it's it's it's some [__] but it's
like a it's a chest deep so you you
could is it a hot tub or like a dipping
pool yeah it's that's what they're
called that's the new thing I don't know
what the [__] it is they're spinning
small pools as dipping pools really I'm
thinking about putting water it's cold
water you jump in cold water you jump in
but you can heat it up you can't do like
Strokes in it but you can have a couple
can't have a can't have a water polo
match or anything yeah if if there was a
sign at the hotel probably be like
maximum occupancy six really seven how
deep is it it's about it goes up chest
High maybe like that's a chilling pool
that's all you need diving board no no
no I mean that would be it would be coup
I mean it is probably like I don't know
two of these tables what's the uh the
grass situation you got a lawn front
yard who's cutting that I have a
gardener nice La calls them gardeners
they're landscap lawn guys or landscap
lawn guys is crazy I got hey the lawn gu
here yeah it just uh yeah it just the
guy I got it from the house he's like
here's I like I hate doing here's
everybody I use and you just 100% I hate
doing anything that's why I wanted a
place I was like ready to just go I
don't want to fix like fix her up are
great it's fun get a personality but
like for me no I just want to continue
life how it's going kids got a [__]
house man look at you that's [__]
awesome than it's on the outskirts of
it's it's like far from all this like
I'm not in the like my neighbors are old
it's residential my neighbor rakes the
street every morning just nothing he has
dementia and he hates his wife and he's
just out there every morning it's like
it's like not like a fun area but like I
love the house and I work out there I I
got a few employees that come over every
day we all edit and work and do [__]
together so it's like it's a business
for me nice close to the podcast garage
no garage no garage driveway yeah
driveway but no garage weird gate no
security guards no okay I got cameras
though he's got the crazy guy in the
street I got I just got the cameras too
you feel real cozy but all the camera is
is really like oh there's my cat oh
here's there's the mail dropping a
carton of eggs like all content baby all
my ring camera sees is me flipping it
off and then just like farting while
opening a door sure you know huh that's
all right man okay that is all right
nothing new you didn't get a new bed
anything like that no new bed still got
the king size though still got the king
size have you upgraded the car no what
car did I have when I did Mercedes I
think or BMW i BMW I have a Tesla now
but it's uh just an LA piece of [__] guy
over here but it's a cheap one model
three it's not the one with the
no no no no see see those are nuts I had
an Uber pick me up in that I felt like
the big all of my neighbors were out
front and that guy rolls up with the
lambo do look at like what the [__] yeah
exactly he's like how you doing Mr Ro
I'm like a [__] don't do this to me yeah
see my level I like to get like
something um I'll get the cheapest but
the nicest so I got the the cheapest
version of it but like the package on it
got you know so I feel like that's where
like my level in life is charger at the
house charger at the house yeah yeah
yeah bad charger if we came to the new
house right now let's go and you offered
us a bottle you offered us water what
would what would we get would we get a
bottle would we get my favorite brand
it's called the sink okay right out of
the tap yeah the tap I mean I I don't
know like I drank it when I first moved
in I didn't have water cuz I usually was
just like looking for a fridge or like a
spout thing I drank it for a month and I
was like I feel fine there's no yeah
there yeah I mean it's fine kid so I
just sink it up what's in the fridge
right now it's it's like the typical
like MTV Cribs
Lin up it's like it's like Prime energy
drinks liquid death all the sponsors of
the show all the spor dogs or something
those those he's got pants in there yeah
listen if you're hydrated come to my
place yeah there's no food in there it's
just a bunch of drinks and like a random
half dip of buffalo ranch or something I
got to tell you those Prime energy
drinks are all right not bad I I the
orange ones fantastic oh really oh
delicious but I watched cribs growing up
and like when they when guys had a
separate fridge for drinks I was like
that's you know you made EP a class
epitome of class and so I got this
little tiny fridge probably about the
same size is that one back there just
with drinks I'm like oh you got that in
the crib yeah cuz it's like it's like a
twoot it's like a townhouse type field
so there's a downstairs where I just
work and edit with the two other guys I
put like a mini fridge down there just
drinks and I feel so cool shoes off in
the house no okay did you dog do when
you moved did you move your
microwave did the house come with a
microwave the house both yeah it with a
microwave in the place before that had a
microwave so I bought a place and these
[__] ripped it out of the wall
dude like like like dude I walked in the
first day with the keys I'm like here we
go babe open up the door I'm like
there's something off about this like
there's just wires hanging out clearly
they needed it more than you I'll get a
microwave I can get a microwave but just
picture them on their day of like we got
to take the microwave I know they did
leave an air hockey table though really
yeah but that's that's just not of
convenience it's that was for them yeah
but they like put a the bow on it and
they're like you're welcome yeah I'm
like this is no I just got to move this
you want to carry air hocket table down
four flights of stairs I know yeah all
the silverware match you got a whole set
no [__] no there's there's one that's
like I went to a nice restaurant they
had like a nice like matte black like
knife and I was like need this I got
yeah so you went out and dude that's
like that's swinger [__] you got black
silverware That's crazy dude just one
that's my upside down pineapple it's
just the one black knife be like wait
you stole that one yes wa was it a steak
knife or a butter knife butter knife huh
but it it looked like the if you walk
past it fast enough like is that a steak
Knife it can play a steak Knife yeah but
it's like it's random [__] or my mom my
parents live like 30 minutes from me so
my Mom will like send me home with a
meal and then there's a fork in there or
something really wow that's so sweet
yeah and so half my Tupperware is just
[__] that my mom gives me or [__] that
like Postmates gives me none of my
Tupperware matches getting Tupperware
from your parents is the best that's
that's never going back oh never never
they gave me a glass bowl one day I hey
you got a fruit bowl now it's a
centerpiece 100% do you make your bed
every morning no nothing no I'll like
I'll do it I'll kind of like you know
I'll throw it okay throw the corners
just so it's presentable any show
pillows in there no just straight
sleeping pillows yeah sleeping pillows
you living out of the oh sorry that's
how you know I don't live with a woman
there's like you look at my bed and it's
like who fought this thing who went bare
knuckle with this sit and
sleep it's like it just looks like
there's lumps and like two pillows don't
match sure different yeah different
color pillowcases and [__] yeah is there
plans to do anything in the house to to
upgrade anything of course yeah I I I'm
leaving it more blank and be waiting to
not [__] it up and then hopefully I find
love with the lady and she's like oh
this wall that wall cuz the worst is I
put something up and she goes why would
you put that there I'm like I don't
[__] I don't want to be drilling
holes in the wall for nonsense sure I
have a lot of like filler are you a
handy guy like that would you hang the
picture do you have any tools at the
house no nothing not a DeWalt drill or
anything like that hammer I got a hammer
get this it's a Four Loco Hammer what
the [__] what man this guy really lives
his brand no they like said you guys
want to get [__]
up I leave that right by the door so if
anybody's breaking in they're like what
the [__] this is crazier than a Glock
they did some brand deal where they sent
me a brick and a hammer for like their
new gold for Loco and I just have a Four
Loco brick and a Four Loco Hammer so I
do have a hammer at the house and a
brick and a brick things are going great
he that gang get 7 billion views on
Instagram and a bunch of four Locos
can a brick and a and a damn Hammer
let's go I like it okay okay couple
questions uh just about uh growing up
yep two things one when was the first
time you had Nutella oh wow probably
when I was eight or nine really that was
in the house yeah but it was on a higher
up shelf like I had to get permission
you know how Nickelodeon was like ask
for your parents before you go online it
was one of those no kidding yeah I think
I classy parents had n tell in the house
my mom was super healthy and I don't
know if I said this last time I was on
it my mom was like very healthy she
wouldn't let me have cereal with
anything more than seven gram of sugar
really so six and Below which is the
worst that's not what were you rocking
oh I mean it was like maybe maybe like
Frost and Mini Wheats if I was good
they're all right though they're great
but the treat Saturday morning watching
SpongeBob eating mini weats like this
guy's going to shoot up a family dude
that's not good it was a lot of like
stuff that like you would think my mom
would like try to spin it like kick
cereal maybe like maybe I don't know p
man that's honees of Oats honey butes
oats is all right those are those are a
sneaky one CU you feel mature as an
8-year-old eating that dude I thought
you had to have gray hair to eat those
things that that's raisin brand true we
had a lot of raisin brand the the the uh
I can't remember I think it's Kellogg's
raisin brand those raisins are [__]
coated with sugar are they really yeah
that was all right man you let that soak
in the milk for a little bit not too
shabby she brought great drink raisin
brand milk is
crazy that's why we're the fattest
podcast around gang raisin
milk that's crazy and did you have a
Power Wheels growing up no what is that
P the car that drives by itself uhuh the
little the little tiny like a be like a
little Escalade or something oh no I
didn't I didn't no I wanted one big
wheel you have a big wheel no uh is that
I had one where you would like it was
like a three wheel and You' like spin
backwards and you like burn out big
wheel yeah that was like [__] cocaine
for an
8-year-old on that that adrenaline when
you hit a 360 in front of the
neighborhood hot chick [__] whipping
work out the streets dude yeah gone in
90 seconds I'm sorry am I Vin
Diesel this is for my family you're
seven I live A4 mile at a
time uh
okay do you wear um underwear under your
bathing suit no dog C you just raw are
you doing like a bathing suit or board
shorts I go board shorts but if a brand
sends me some [__] and they got like the
liner and it I'll wear it how many of
those do you have how many bathing suits
probably like five I'm a big like if
somebody sends me something I'm keeping
it you know so a lot of times like some
random like Seltzer brand is like we our
new board shorts I'm like sure what
about suits what's your suit situation
um I have one suit and I name brand I
don't know what it is it's it's like a
name brand but
it's it's Four
Loco it's a gold Four Loco suit what's
up you guys try to party yeah yeah yeah
I'm Riff Raff's manager over
here yeah sir this is a
funeral I it's it's a I forget what it
was it's a it's a name brand but it's
like the lowest on like the the could be
big name brand you know Mark Jacobs it
might be it's it's like respectable to
like somebody going to prom but like if
you went to like the Met Galler they'd
be like get out of here we parking cars
going to prom yeah yeah yeah it's one of
those it's it's it's cool okay when was
the last time you wore it probably a
wedding like a year ago okay yeah a lot
of class coming out of this kid these
days I'll be honest with you hey thank
you thank you he did just say his only
tools a gold for Loco hmer all right
just got the house yeah I'm like a
wonderball you never know what side of
Trevor you're
getting okay all right well let's get
into some [__] uh questions from the
homies gang as you know when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air uh Mr Trevor Wallace
Here Yeah by a [__] goddamn internet
sensation um speaking of houses pools
this is from David $10 homie haven't had
one read is a garbage have a blowup hot
tub in your basement
that's those are getting popular blow up
hot tub in the basement no just a blowup
hot tub in general are getting because
they're super cheap really you got like
Walmart or Costco for two 300 bucks it's
better than anybody doing ice baths so
if you're going to have any tub of water
in a random place of your house make it
be a hot tub you don't like a cold
plunge I do but the personality that
comes with it it's tough It's like you
do it and you have to tell somebody
you're like uh it's like hiking you're
like I [__] need to post the top of
the hike it's intermittent fasting it's
all that the second you do something the
second you improve your life life at all
you're like everybody has to find about
this the same way I annoyed the [__] out
of him when we were down the Jersey
Shore cuz the water was freezing and we
were in there and I I love a cold plunge
yeah just my [__] the wor is they are
the feeling after you're like oh this is
it's so it's a natural high we were in
the water and he's like it's freezing
I'm like I love it I love it I love it
he's big on he thinks the ocean is a
cold plunge no well that uh he thinks
certain things I got a bag ice out there
him interesting oh I see so you know
what I mean he's the kind of guy who's
like love cold water it's just my like
not even a cold I'm like we jumped in
the water it was like 52 degre oh man
that's cold feels good though it feels
good I'm like I understand that it feels
good I'm just commenting on the
temperature that it is cold I love it if
I was out there you should get a cold
plunge you should get an infrared sauna
back there oh I might well the the one
thing one of the brands was like I made
a video about ice bath like talking [__]
and like we'll send you ours and I was
like yeah dude but then my first thought
was if I move like what the it's going
to be the like the air hockey table sure
yeah the real estate agent's like here's
the house you get a free cold plunge
there's four Locos in it Hammer not
included yeah yeah yeah uh oh yeah that
makes sense okay but you did say hot
inflatable hot tub in the basement the
basement's no good I feel that's too
much heat that's too much humidity in
there you're [__] down there oh yeah
that's dirty you want to see my basement
hot tub she's like I don't want to see
your basement yeah it's got to be a
finished basement but then that might
make it worse an un dude a hot tub and
an unfinished BAS is wild to me it
sounds like a man about to have a
divorce you know honey let me have this
this is my this is my
manave goes down there sounds a coid
idea that stuck sure you know can't
leave sure I don't know the gloves are
really off during Co weren't thing it's
just everybody [__] nothing was like
questioned you're like yeah that checks
out yeah we're doing this this is what
we're doing you be doing squats in your
kitchen couches outside no g a [__] the
hard part is how is he going to get the
water out of that how's he going to move
that up
you know yeah how do you get the water
out of there I guess it's like a water
bed you put the hose in there and suck
it out a little bit siphon it yeah but
from the no but you're starting
low I don't know you [__] yeah that
that's coming with house how do you get
the water out that's coming with that's
what I'm saying you'd have P you put a
couple baa fish in there now it's a zoo
you you do you an aquarium you throw
some pump in there we have a pump that
takes the water off the top of the cover
on the pool I think it's a sump pump
short no it's not a sump pump that's
just a pump I think yeah pump you
rocking a house no my parents have an
above ground pool and the rainwater gets
on top of
hey not bad it's we've talked about a
lot on the show it's it would blow your
mind the side it's the biggest olympic
size it's the biggest above ground pool
I've ever seen does that water ever
circulate or change yeah yeah she got to
when it
rains get a good rain going yeah it's
full right now we had a lot of rain last
week nice dude they've then decked
so it's like you walk up on the whole
backyard is a deck remember Mr miyagi's
backyard how it was all deck yeah yeah
yeah it's not that cool it's not well
Daniel Russo is not back there doing
karate but it's it's it's it's like say
this is the pool T you walk up into the
backyard upstairs and then you're
elevated 4T or 5T whatever the pool is
and then the pool is the whole entire
backyard and there's not a blade of
grass in the whole back it's all one I
love that it's like the opposite of an
infinity pool it's a Night Pool it's the
craziest thing I've ever seen he's like
yeah I got to pool I walked over I'm
like this is the [__] most white
trash [__] I've ever seen how do you get
into an above pool is there like a
ladder is there like a you can
step that's they built it's like anr
pool yeah yeah they got a guy doing
daies by the side there's a swim up
bar Char room 602 please yeah dude
that's nice sounds a good place to
relapse or get clean yeah uh try for a
couple of days all right speaking of
basement as well this one's from Rick uh
is it garbage have a shooting range in
your basement of your home big basement
theme today oh man we're in it tonight
shooting rang in your home that I I that
doesn't make any sense to me it's like
the back of guns and ammo yeah your
neighbors got to be pissed yeah I was
going to say it's not insane to have it
in there but what do the neighbors know
I don't think this I don't think he made
it like a I think he's just shooting his
gun in his basement like there's not
like just shooting hay stacks yeah I
don't think he's like lined it with like
soundproofing or there's not like the
chain that you pull up like that's when
you're getting ready to assassinate
somebody when you're doing that that
seems like an an article would come out
and like we saw his basement he was
shooting DUI crash test dummies yeah
yeah I was picturing like blown apart
mannequins yeah it's it's a slippery
slope you know there are those things
though I don't know what they are but
they're like pipes where that's like a
shooting range where you shoot the gun
down a pipe and it just just like
ricochets down there I saw it on
Instagram I don't know what it was I
don't I think it was in somebody's house
that was his shooting range maybe at
something like that yeah it's not
necessarily a garbage maybe has that
thing hey maybe has that thing I just
made
up it definitely sounds like he's 3D
printing his own guns in the basement
yeah that's kind go to his shooting
range get out talk to some people yeah
you know what I mean you know maybe get
some of those ideas out of your head
yeah it's crazy it's a little bizarre I
mean I would I'm going downstairs to
shoot guns yeah uh and write letters
with magazine
clippings where's my Scot
tape I kind of let the president know
what's going on slippery slope the only
way I can see you're doing it is if
you're doing it and you don't have n
that's got to be loud cuz like a range
you're shooting a lot you're not just
shooting one you're shooting a lot it's
a basement the sound is just going to be
I mean his ears got to be blown to [__]
not Dimension you're probably going to
pop the hot
tub yeah was this the same guy also
shoot shooting a gun from a hot tub
we're I'm back in yeah hold on that's
all
right here you put it like that yeah Al
paccino [__] right there just kind to
lined up on the stairs nice yeah that's
not bad oh damn that's good uh all right
let's see here this one's from Paul is
it garbage if you use the Bluetooth
earpiece as an
11-year-old Jesus so like I guess when
he was 11 he's probably in his 20s now
Bluetooth earpieces just dropped and he
had like the oh he was using it at 11 I
love that did you guys miss that or was
that that never got cool that never
picked up you had to be an uncle to have
one of those and you I love the guys at
the airport they rock my favorite is the
people at the airport that have like an
Xbox Live Headset for their music oh
I've never seen or look like anybody or
it looks like they the drive-thru for
music yeah it's like they just it's like
like they went in their kids' room
grabbed somebody I need headphones I'm
going to Cleveland I've honestly seen it
probably like five times but it's like
it's like the it's like a gamer headset
and then they have the mic and it's just
like some six year old dad sitting at a
bar J I remember those Bluetooth
earpieces where guys would take like
family pictures oh yeah they would have
that in and whenever they had one of
those in they were always holding one of
those yards I think I think a Bluetooth
headset comes with a tooth pick to use
at the same time it's like a very one-w
combo I don't think I think that that
like that technology never fully got
there yeah you know what I mean like the
airpods it was now the air it's like it
wanted to be what the airpod was and at
the time was so one airpod's pretty
annoy too can I say that the one the one
yeah you look like a psychopath you
talking to yourself or you're making a
call yeah I do think seeing a guy with a
Bluetooth headset in 2023 I respect that
man that guy's that guy's made that a
part of his personality and he's in it
yeah that guy's been a warn back that
guy's making a lot of sales for minimum
commission yeah exactly if beepers came
back would you rock a beeper and did you
ever have prob close to come phones are
beepers essentially somebody calls you
like why the [__] and then you text them
what's going on Gary Gman has the great
line
my phone is just an app on my phone yeah
exactly like an unused app on my phone
never use it true um I would use a pager
yeah I had I did have I had a pager as a
kid no one ever paged me once it's quite
sad and then the batteries ran out I
never didn't know how to charge it or
something they took like those little
watch batteries stop selling that weak
[__] no clientel baby yeah I don't think
the Bluetooth is trashy I think I think
it's an 11-year-old being like I want to
stand out he's trying to be cool and at
that time it probably was a cool
technology it's better than having a
[__] Yo-Yo at 11 so you know we do
probably closing more ass with a [__]
with the mom you have fun I'll be then
five like what is he I that's what I
want to know what kind of calls he yeah
you don't need to be you're not
receiving he a phone on his ear that's
something he saw his stepdad doing yeah
exactly and man a kid that would just
randomly break out a
yo-yo I was not sleep cradle you know
that [__] I was kind of that kid if
we're being honest
oh man I just felt that guy's two guns
turn on me I'm in the basement right now
baby it's just like that's that's a I
don't know man that's like was a
different time it was the 9 a gateway
drug to being a magician right there it
definitely it definitely led to the
devil's scks I'll tell you devil sticks
dude what are the devil sticks those
little you hit the thing back here you
did those it was he did them in a talent
show what no out a talent show how old
how old College how old do you want to
here
at an all girl school it was for my
sority no I it's so I was doing the
devil sticks I was pretty good at them
you had no competition nobody in tell
nobody in town is doing live
Habachi I was the best in the county uh
wow and I there was I I think it was for
camp or something it was a town show and
I was like you know I was I was a
showman at it's got fat camp written all
over it
yeah but if you have a thing at that age
you're coming out forward with that
you're leading with that oh did I have
them on me for sure really and they
don't fit in any pocket your back pocket
riding up your T-shirt like the lamest
drummer in history yeah so Jesus so well
I was I was really good at not really I
was proficient okay I was proficient at
them and then I so we did the we did the
dress rehearsal for you know the rehe
dress rehearsal you ran Tech yeah yeah
yeah no the problem is we did ACL yeah
the whole thing we didn't run Tech and I
didn't know there was going to be a
light package going off during the real
show so they didn't know you know they
hit me with strobe lights and I could
dude I would send it up in the air and I
couldn't that's like that when you do a
Guitar Hero on xer or something what the
[__] is this Dragon
for and I lost I I couldn't I couldn't
land a trick dude how did you recover I
I I didn't I got an accommodated you
just disappeared one of the strobe
lights and all of a sudden you were gone
your sticks are just on the ground he
disappeared ah yeah it was a bad scene
did you do anything like that as a kid
was there hacky sack hula hoop no I've
always been so unathletic I play the
drums in high school only because my
parents made me play an instrument were
you any good a decent very very minimum
level I could play four songs any band
attempts no no band attempt I played it
like a chore my parents would be like
you can go play with your friends if you
do 15 minutes of drums and I pick drums
respect that though yeah it was my dad
played drums growing up so and my mom
played like the flute or violin some
white [__] and they were like you got to
play an instrument to follow suit of the
family so I was like I I did drums cuz
it was the most like angsty teen and
like oh I'm play loud as possible shout
out to Mr and Mrs Wallace good structure
over there great structure would the old
man jump down there and and show you how
to do it yeah yeah you'd hop on he's got
a drum set my old room is now just a
drum set so when I go home I get to
sleep on the couch or my sister's room
damn just a drum set in the room middle
of the room small room just a drum set
it's like from Step
Brothers literally I'm like Dad what
where am I supposed to sleep the high
hat what am I doing here dude that's a
tough look man yeah I mean like it's I
just walked a pelaton a treadmill
something like that I felt like I was
meeting like I think it's cool yeah it
felt like when you meet like one of your
friends like college buddies you're like
who the [__] is this guy that's hated
that or your college friends friends
from home Bill he here this weekend and
they don't jail yeah it's just weird
where you feel like you're responsible
for making them friends yeah that was
always tough one but yeah and I did put
my nuts on his drum sack so just had to
get that out there and then we fought in
the front
yard uh all right let's see here this is
from Brody uh are you garbage if you
spent multiple thanksgivings on vacation
and ate Thanksgiving dinners at Hooter
Jesus man any any holidays eaten out uh
I'm Jewish so we do uh Christmas always
do Chinese food that's dude you have no
idea how jealous I was all my je oh man
dude phenomenal chin in a movie yeah
Chinese in a movie it's so funny we just
like do anything to take away from the
fact that it's Christmas yeah there's no
Christmas it's the best there is nothing
better than a sit down nice Chinese
restaurant love Chinese dude [__] the
best but the the Hooters on here is uh
up until Hooters I was like I feel like
that's pretty normal it's a tradition
sure if you're away yeah I would love to
see the people at Hooters not only the
people eating there but the staff
working on a Thursday on Thanksgiving
Thursday yeah that holiday everybody's
everybody celebr the amount of times an
old guy makes a stuffing joke towards
one of the waitresses oh man I wish I
was stuffing something else Veronica
what time you off are those wings bone
in yeah yeah yeah help me with the
drumstick will you yeah I didn't get
that one what do you mean drum you
drumstick on the turkey yeah uh Toby cut
that leave it
in um were you a Hooters guy or kid at
all like what was your first Hooters
experience you you guys are going to
love this my dad took me to Hooters for
my 13th birthday Jesus Christ and he
didn't tell my mom he didn't tell my mom
he said we were going somewhere else we
went to the Hooters in Burbank and I had
a pregnant waitress and so they didn't
made they made me do this thing where
told he's having an
affair he good news my dad's making out
with the waitress yeah it's your tip
honey but they make you do the thing
when you're it's your birthday there
where you put a a cup in your mouth like
the little like snow cone looking ones
okay and you flap your wings and they
sing
The Chicken Song and they make you do
that but dude I was 13 in my head I'm
like yo these chicks want to [__] damn
oh they're making me sing a song I'll
walk the walk but in my head I was like
they're hitting on me but I'm 13 in
Burbank pregnant waiters on and that
same day I went to Chinatown and got a
ninja star for my birthday with my dad
whoa yeah Dad great that's a [__]
wild birthday dad Splurge for the 13th
birthday yeah Chinatown and Hooters
that's a onew combo just you and him he
took you to Hooters me him and my other
one friend that's awesome yeah any
explaining going on about Hooters to you
guys jugs or
anything that's now son you're a man
this is what we call athetic typ of
breast here today you know uh I don't
think so I think he was like my dad's
like a not like a [__] like Alpha guy
like I think he was just as impressed by
the tits as I was like both of us are
probably just wide-eyed and speechless
dad stop looking at him yeah we're just
two drunk guys in a DUI line he's ahead
of
us did you know he was taking you to
Chinatown get a to get a ninja start I
think I requested that and I think
Hooters like I think my mom was okay
with that part but the Hooters was extra
I think the Hooters my dad's like I
think you a [__] Hooters man that's
[__] cool as [__] that's an all right
13th I went to Hooters with a ninja star
in my pocket I mean that's crazy that's
all right that's crazy [__] Lethal
Weapon the teeth ready to do some
creeping dude I yeah exactly I think I
still have the ninja star but that was
like a great birthday yeah that's all
right yeah I'd tell you the first
experience I want to have that birthday
now dude I really do take me to get some
weapons and some tits let's do it that's
dude weapons and gazungas who doesn't
love that locked and
loaded man it's a double feature that's
all right I mean the think you could do
that now when is last thing guys went to
a Hooters not that long ago yeah two
years ago May yeah within two years in
Fort Worth that's a good place to see I
it was Fort wor yeah you ever done a but
they were just about to close and they
were not happy we were there D we also
did a Twin Peaks one those San Antonio
yeah it's like it's the Texas Hooters
which we had no idea it was just like in
it was in the sanan Antonio one it's
like right by the LOL right by LOL did I
go there yeah and we walked in I'm like
Twin Peak I just thought it was like I
don't know like a mountaineering bar or
something big David Lynch fans yeah you
put twin pece like oh mountains and it
wasn't it wasn't until the beers got Dro
start putting shock on your hands like
what are we grabbing but yeah I um have
you ever been have you ever done House
of Comedy in the Mall of America no
Minnesota but it's uh to walk to that
club you stay in the hotel in the mall
and then to walk there you pass the
Hooters and I went to one of the Hooters
there by myself Hooters as an adult is
kind of sad you it's not great you look
at the bar and you're like half these
dudes have dementia oh and they're just
drooling out the mount they're 93 and
you're like this is not we got to get
some frat guys in here stat yeah it's
not you think the commercial would be
like it's frat dudes we're hang we're
here for the game but it's like an old
watering hole for old Ronnie the Korean
war vet his wife died suddenly 5 years
ago now he's looking for coupons and
[__] and plus sometimes they do the
leggings the the the skin tone leggings
they do that it's their thing I think no
they do the orange orange booty shorts
yeah but I think with the leggings
that's their thing with like the real
tan leggings you're right not the real
deal what you doing here show some let's
press some flesh ladies probably health
code violation yeah you can't have your
[__] cooch Chang now speeding my hair
and food Jesus Christ that ain't no
eyelash I'll tell you
that
uh all right let's see this one's from
Christian $14 Canadian shareholder shout
out to you uh goddamn exchange rate
haven't had one red ever falling asleep
at a funeral that's a bad look dude I do
get it it is very ASMR there it's very
One Tone it's also like you have to be a
certain level detached from the family
you can't it can't be like your cousin
or something and you're falling asleep
it's got to you got to be a you got to
be associated with people there I'll say
this as a Catholic I don't know what
it's like at uh at synagogue but there's
just something sleepy about church oh I
there's only so many times you can hear
See You Again by Charlie poth and Whiz
Khalifa before you start dozing
on see
you I would just pretend that I was role
playing I like oh see what uncle was
like I'm visiting him in heaven get off
my back yeah I seeing God uh yeah that's
tough that's a tough look can't be can't
be falling asleep at a I think I think
you're right it sounds like a big
disconnect maybe there I don't know if
we actually last because you should be
grieve like you should be in an
emotional state where you're like I just
lost whoever this suck you just get
tired in there I don't know why it also
feels weird to like get ready I remember
I went to a funeral when I was in like
eighth grade I'm like spiking my hair
I'm like the [__] am I doing who's this
for nice yeah right we hit Hooters after
use as a comb did you ever do this the
snowplow just like the straight out G oh
I'm sure I have I I think my hair has
been like a compass it's just been in
every direction at some point I think
yeah I did the bleach frosted tips I
don't know if I did like fully out
oh yeah the tips e maybe like middle
school but just the top part really I
mean this was big like Lance Bass I was
I was a big you know you were a big
Lance Bass guy I didn't like the music
but I just saw him I was like that's
that's the guy those guys were cool if
anybody's [__] it's Lance Bass I met
him super cool yeah wow what do you
smell like I forget SM but yeah I only
would do like the cir like the top like
right here but that was in like you
wouldn't do the whole head we would do
the whole head we would shade we would
die or like whatever B it was em& I mean
that was it and then you would shave the
like you would trim the the hair the top
would stay longer than the sides yeah
you get a couple weeks out of the sides
I remember I used to have my mom go buy
like [__] women's hair dye and we dye
my hair and I was like sitting there
watching like WWF or whatever she was
just like what the [__] is wrong with
this [__] yapping about the neighborhood
gossip I got a
magazine uh all right let's see here
let's do a couple more um this one's
just wild this is from Kyle uh just did
this last week uh are you garbage if you
wash and dry a fresh pack of sigs but
still smoke them afterwards dot dot dot
they tasted a little funny oh yeah
dude I mean that's just bath salt at
that point that's not just smoking Tide
Pods once once the heaters get wet it's
over but then dried probably with fabric
softener dry oh I didn't even think
about drying what the those are some
good cigarettes that aren't breaking
well made I guess if they're in the Box
they they're not getting jostled around
I don't know hey man 15 bucks is 15
bucks fire him up dude I got shit's
gross I got hit for 19 the other night
in New York 19 bucks for a pack of
heaters the hell's going on in this
goddamn these weren't even washed what
the
[__] pay for dirty I will say when you
go to like a Vegas nightclub you know
the the attendant in the bathroom
they've upgraded dude they had like
Vapes it was like a bod in there oh they
got Vapes they got Vapes in there and
this is my audience is it just a hit off
of Vape or do you take the
Vape I don't know how jamed up are you
wall and you he's like all right that's
enough 3 seconds you're done you're done
no blinkers no blinkers yeah yeah yeah
but this is my fan base God this guy's
amazing I'm washing my hands I don't
even Vape people just look at me and go
that guy Vapes oh yeah yeah so this guy
goes it would be an honor to buy you a
vape and I'm like what am I going to say
no to a free vape and yeah I just bought
a vape I take it back to the table and
with I'm coughing I was like somebody
bow me this but they they were $40 wa J
but that's supply and demand it's a
bunch of drunk kids you're drunk you
need one you and your yeah they're not
checking IDs it's it's it's beautiful
it's like a bodega in there now yeah $40
damn that's all right have you ever used
the cologne in a a all time I I think I
use that to get my money wor I'll use
the Lifesaver mints I'll use a gum
mouthwash I use everything if they got a
winter Green in there I'm taking it and
a little Spritz of something a little
Spritz of jup or something like that you
putting it on no really that's yeah
never no cuz I want to come back to my
date and she's like what the [__] did he
do in there f aboc were you just making
out with a Russian dude in the bathroom
what's going on here yeah I I in my head
I come back and I'm like this is new
like refreshed man you feel fresh yeah
especially in a town like New York
you're walking around you're sweating
you got different like layers on you
Spritz up a little bit dude dude like
today like I literally pack for New York
like I'm going to a sleepover like my
backpack has like two waters a coffee
three shirts deodorant and gel yeah
you're going to yeah you're I don't even
have a
toothbrush got powder tooth too busy
just using it as a bathroom key
somewhere yeah what do you guys think on
what's your take on like the bathroom
keys I I used to have a joke it was like
the bigger the key the Sketcher the area
the bigger the Oh you mean likey like
gas station 100% yeah God those are so
funny if it's on like a hub cap if it's
on if it's on a weapon I've gotten them
where they're on like a billy CL it's on
like a club we were just somewhere where
the [__] were we usually the club of a
uh a squeegee you know we just saw that
in California I that was the first time
I saw that I was like this is just a
[__] broken squeegee it's a yeah it's
a night stick yeah it was on our way to
San Diego and there was a woman shower
in the bathroom California baby yeah man
that was a rough bathroom did you guys
have big bathroom passes in like Middle
School High School uh yes yeah yeah you
one of ours was like pass yeah a hall
pass one of ours was a legit chain like
something that like Terry crw would use
like work out with at like a yard like
like a chain and you would hear it
walking through the Halls yeah we just
had they
we would just make up whatever or like
how here take this to show you have some
sort of yeah that was like the the funny
teacher would do like a toilet
handle I'm just laying it on the ground
I don't like I don't cuz you get in
there the person who had it before you
was putting it on the trash can in the
sink now I'm touching it I'm a
germaphobe I don't I don't even like
touching the [__] you thinking about
that [__] as a kid oh yeah Jesus Christ
have a a Decap this going to get on my
demon sticks devil sticks sorry sorry
sorry sorry demon sticks all right we
got to wrap it up though gang gang Mr
Trevor Wallace thank you for having me
it's so fun onour
Budd we love you new Amazon special
dropping November 14 14th pterodactyl
you check it out pterodactyl please do
if you know how to spell it P T E R I
just had some trouble uh's leading it
with a t yeah it's a t t e r d a c t l
terod now that's
pterodactyl that's how we spell It in
America yeah there's a y in there too no
there's not swear on my life Jesus I
think it's d y l there's no a
[__] scientist always got to be
[__] showing off I like I decided
name and then I was like is it are
people going to be like trying to type
it on their Amazon be like you also made
it the hardest word no I told them I had
a call with them yesterday I was like
make it like the search data be like if
you're spelling with a t you can still
find it you know or even make it like
the pterodactyl we got Foley over there
I want him to be able to find like T W's
gonna be calling you freaking out I
can't find it November 14th Che it out
congratulations one of the funniest one
of the
one of the most successful kicking ass
guys around Trevor Wallace Kippy what do
you got for him uh guys we're also all
over the road uh that second Philly show
is solding out there's the out of a
fourth show in Chicago and a third show
in Toronto get those [__] tickets
gang we love you yeah we'll see you next
week peace peace